Yuichi Katagiri is the one who likes the way he touches his 8 hair
.
No matter who likes who, there's no reason to blame someone for dating someone in the past
Still, it's not something that can be easily resolved, is
it?
Did
you know that you liked me?
There's a relationship
I'm from Shiho-chan I
know her very well
Stop it and turn it into an exhibition Such a way of speaking that's open to the public On the
5th floor I didn't say anything, but Mikasa and I are
childhood friends I am  Mikasa's father is a police officer, and Mikasa's
father is a public prosecutor
.  Until
Ohanasaku's father passed away two years ago
Then Mikasa changed his mind and we met again by chance in high school last year
.
If the two of you had zero romantic feelings, it would be a lie
Your remarks about Mr. Sawaragi, police officers, and
frustrated exhibits